BUT NOW MY OPENING STATEMENT.
THE REASON THAT ROBERT MUELLER
SPOKE PUBLICLY THIS WEEK IS
BECAUSE HE WAS MORE WORRIED
ABOUT HIS LEGACY THAN HE WAS IN
PROTECTING THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS COUNTER TO EVERYTHING HE
WAS TAUGHT AND SUPPOSEDLY STOOD
FOR AND IS NOT ONLY
DISAPPOINTING BUT POLITICALLY
DAMAGING.
MUELLER WAS CHARGED WITH SERVING
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
NOT HIS EGO.
BUT THAT IS EXACTLY HOW HE'LL
NOW BE REMEMBERED.
MUELLER HAD A CASE OF SELLER'S
REMORSE.
WHEN THE SELLER REGRETS WHAT
HE'S ALREADY SOLD.
IT SEEMS BOB IS AFFLICTED WITH A
SERIOUS CASE OF REMORSE.
THE ORIGINAL REPORT DIDN'T HURT
TRUMP ENOUGH.
ASK YOURSELF ONE QUESTION.
WHY AFTER 10 WEEKS, AFTER THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL REPORT IS
SUBMITTED DOES MUELLER
UNILATERALLY DECIDE TO HOLD A
PRESS CONFERENCE TO SAY HE'S
CLOSING SHOP?
AND WHY DOES MUELLER DO A JIM
COMEY AND SAY I DIDN'T CHARGE
BUT ONLY BECAUSE DOT DOT DOT.
HE DOES IT TO RALLY THE LEFT
BECAUSE THE MUELLER REPORT
DIDN'T HURT ENOUGH.
MIND YOU, THE REPORT IS THE BEST
EVIDENCE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
IT IS THE INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS NO NEED TO UNILATERALLY
EMPHASIZE OR ADD TO THE
DOCUMENT.
NOT ROBERT MUELLER.
HE DECIDES TO JUMP INTO THE
POLITICAL FRAY JUST LIKE HIS PAL
JIM COMEY DID.
NOW THE CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT
ARE ECHOING THROUGHOUT CONGRESS.
THIS WAS NOT THE CASE WHEN THE
REPORT WAS COMMITTED.
SO MUELLER I IMAGINE AS THE
BEHEST OF THE LEFT GIVES THEM
WHAT THEY NEED TO JUMP-START THE
CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
BUT NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN THE
REPORT.
THE ONLY THING THAT CHANGED IS
MUELLER DECIDE SOMETHING CREATE
CHAOS AND HAVOC, AS IF TWO YEARS
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT SHOW
NO OBSTRUCTION OR COLLUSION ARE
NOT ENOUGH.
BUT THAT'S WHAT MUELLER DID.
MUDDY UP THE WATERS AND CHARGE
UP THE LEFT.
>> THAT INVESTIGATION IF WE HAD
HAD CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT CLEARLY DID NOT COMMIT
A CRIME WE WOULD HAVE SAID SO.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEY NEVER SAID
THAT IN THE REPORT.
NOW MUELLER IS ADDING, LOOK, I
AM NOT CONFIDENCE YOU DIDN'T
COMMIT A CRIME.
THAT'S SHEER LUNACY.
I DON'T KNOW A PROSECUTOR IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO EVER SAID AFTER
A GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION I'M
NOT SURE HE DIDN'T COMMIT A
CRIME.
YOU WILL EITHER INDICT OR YOU
DON'T.
YOU DON'T COME OUT AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, I'M NOT INDICTING HIM, BUT
I'M TELLING YOU HE AIN'T A GOOD
GUY.
EVERY PROSECUTOR KNOWS IF YOU
DON'T INDICT SOMEONE, YOU STOP
THERE.
SO WHAT WAS THE POINT OF THE
400-PLUS REPORT.
IT DOESN'T SAY I'M NOT CONFIDENT
YOU DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME.
SO WHAT'S THE END GAME.
LET'S TAKE A SECOND TO CAULK
ABOUT COLLUSION.
NOT THE TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
BUT WHAT ABOUT COLLUSION BETWEEN
MUELLER AND THE DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT THOUGHT OTHER THAN
THEIR HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE MUELLER REPORT DIDN'T
ACCOMPLISH THEIR GOAL.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE.
THEY NEED MULE TORE SHAKE --
THEY NEED MUELLER TO SHAKES
THINGS UP SO THEY CAN RALLY.
>> WE DID NOT MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT DID COMMIT A CRIME.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHY THE HECK NOT?
WHAT DID YOU AND YOUR GANG OF
TRUMP HATING, HILLARY-LOVING
LAWYERS DO FOR TWO YEARS.
HE USES THE EXCUSE THAT THE
GUIDELINES SAY YOU CAN'T INDICT
A SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> HE STATED THREE TIMES THAT HE
WAS NOT SAY HE WITHOUT THE,
OPINION BE HE WOULD HAVE FOUND
OBSTRUCTION.
WHEN WE PRESSED HIM ON IT, HE
SAID HIS TEAM WAS STILL
FORMULATING THE EXPLANATION.
JUDGE JEANINE: STILL FORMULATING
AN EXPLANATION WHY YOU DIDN'T
REACH A DECISION ON OBSTRUCTION?
ARE YOU STUPID?
YOU HAD TWO YEARS TO THINK ABOUT
THAT ONE.
AND HE DID NOT.
INSTEAD HE PUNTED AND NOW
MUELLER WANTS TO COME OUT AND
SAY LOOK, WE NEVER SAID HE
DIDN'T, WE SIMPLY COULDN'T MAKE
A DECISION BECAUSE HE'S A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
FOLKS, THAT'S BALONEY.
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF THIS
INVESTIGATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
WHAT DID YOU DO FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU COULD HAVE REACHED A
CONCLUSION WITHOUT CHARGE BY
SIMPLY STATING YOUR CONCLUSION
OR OPINION.
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN DID YOU
KNOW THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
DID YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE THE MID
TERMS?
YOU COULD HAVE SHUT THE WHOLE
THING DOWN.
BUT THEN AGAIN IT WAS A MAJOR
HELP TO THE DEMOCRATS, WANTS IT?
AND YOU ARE HELPING THEM YET
AGAIN.
LET'S RECAP.
NEITHER THE PRESIDENT NOR ANYONE
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDE
WITH RUSSIA.
YOU CONNED MAKE A DECISION ON
OBSTRUCTION AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAD TO DO SO.
SO WHO THE HELL ASKED YOU TO
COME OUT THIS WEEK AND MUDDY THE
WATERS THE WAY JIM COMEY DID IN
2016.
I GUESS WE HAVE A COMPETITION
BETWEEN HOLIER THAN THOU CRIPPLE
SCOAM COMEY AND ROBERT MUELLER.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL